so
we have a lot of expertise here to help
with this presentation
we have about one and a half minutes
more
for people to finish joining
and as I said to the first people
joining if you want to share with us
where you're from
cool
all right
so we'll get started in about 30 seconds
from the University of jodhpur
cool
okay
and since it's just about the top of the
hour in India I'm going to go ahead and
start
presentation and welcome everyone to
this program preview
of our business analytics program with
IIT rookie
with modules from IBM and my name is
Stuart Creek I'm with simply learn so is
Mohan George we are the delivery partner
for IIT rookie for this particular
program and we have
but with this professor Tarn Sharma who
I'll speak about in just a moment
We'll be asking questions about you
through the process so watch for those
polls
um we're going to be talking about
business analysis and careers in the
field
queer opportunities that you'll have in
the field
then we'll go over what the program from
IIT rookie offers you and how it can get
you job ready for taking a career
embarking on a career business analytics
um
the emphasis of this program also is for
working professionals to add business
analytics skills to their repertoire to
their toolkit so that you are able to do
a better decision making in your work
so
this is a kind of a
multi-layered program for that purpose
we'll go over enrollment steps and a
bonus offer so if you stay with us
through the webinar we will share with
you a special bonus you receive
or being here
this evening and of course
Dr Sharma and mom and George will be
here to
answer your questions
uh Professor if you'd like to
tell us a little bit about yourself
yeah sure thanks to it
yeah uh so I am uh Sharma so I'm
currently a based at uh IIT roorkee so
I'm affiliated with the Department of
management studies so I'm an assistant
professor I uh I'm a assistant professor
in the area of operations management so
I teach courses on um operations in
Supply Chain management uh production
operations planning quality management
and decision models and specifically I
publish in the area of energy policy and
modeling so applying these operations
tools or optimization methods production
planning Etc kind of methods to energy
sector particularly and uh
um yeah I um you know published a few
papers and uh yeah those would be my
teaching engagements and then probably
speak more uh in a while about the the
course contents great thank you and the
energy policy is a very exciting area
um over the last
almost two years now uh with the fact
that uh
the war in Ukraine has disrupted so much
of the world's energy Supply so that on
top of the pandemic
fascinating area
um
we'll talk about careers in business
analysis
why business analysis is so very
important so if you could
share with us professor
why this statement is true
yeah so yeah we can think of uh business
as constituted by multiple processes you
could organize say them across a
functional domains across Metal
Management top-level management or not
it's always been important to sort of
understand these individual processes
group them into sets and then be able to
manage them so essentially to be able to
uh to to to prove the output determine
if it's correct Incorrect and then have
a feedback loop and then be able to
manage uh the processes to cement the
submand could be say being profitable
being resilient being agile or what not
um so these things have been there for
uh so businesses and businesses have
existed for a long time now but
increasingly uh what's been changing uh
is of course that now we have a lot more
visibility of the processes we have lot
more lot more data captures about the
process and then that opens up whole
Avenue of things between to automation
or see maybe controlling the processes
in a better manner motivating employees
or maybe scheduling assigning work
monitoring work controlling process
control process optimization or what no
there's n number of things which could
be done increasingly so because now we
have say uh increasing amounts of data
being captured about processes and then
we have increasing capabilities to store
the data uh in a decentralized manner in
a centralized manner then in fact do
something about the data get some
insight and then be able to do something
about the process and that is the
process of say business analysis uh so
analyzing the component processes
um we have get a bunch of data about it
and then be able to do some analytics on
top of it and then generate some
actionable insights
um and yeah so on the slide we have uh
yeah the first point is about exclusion
of data so I've given you some context
and historically say for this to sketch
uh say the major Paradigm shifts in how
things get done how businesses get done
so we can go all the way back to see a
steam engine uh that electricity uh
programmable logical controllers the
data thing the internet uh what we say
The Internet of Things four uh that
speak the latest a paradigm and along
with comes say uh machine learning data
analytics business analytics for that
matter and increasingly companies have
this as a separate vertical altogether
so bigger companies will have a in-house
say analytics vertical and some other
companies maybe a smaller ones tend to
Outsource sort these things
um so we have the assertion the belief
essentially is that uh these success
depends on uh business analysis this
capability to First capture data analyze
it and then be able to take some
actionable insights to me we become
competitive at the marketplace and of
course
um
the hypothesis this proposition tends to
be confirmed in various pools surveys
and the topic essentially is is quite uh
trendy and topical
and you know the the first business
records that that still exist were
pressed into clay tablets in cuneiform
by the Babylonians so yeah back when
when that was done you couldn't really
do much with the data other than refer
back to it as a historical record
um fast forward to our modern day where
not only can you record the data but you
can actually manipulate it you can use
it in calculations and you can then
start to extract
information insights projections from it
so we live in a very different time
and
especially uh
just jump in there Stuart and sorry for
cutting you I think earlier we'd say an
experienced manager is is worldwide but
increasingly that uh experience uh sort
of which uh is sort of learning uh basis
exposure to the data to the process over
extended period of time of need
analytics has sort of come to replace
that to some extent it's possible to
sort of tease out insights see which
otherwise will take a long years to
accumulate in some person's head uh see
if it's a pretty exposure over a long
period of time softly so that is sort of
the saying that the experience managers
is better than uh say uh maybe a new
hire or maybe a technically competent
manager but then off late then that's
changing uh to some extent yeah and and
the important thing is to understand
um we we always get questions about how
for example artificial intelligence will
impact these types of careers and the
important thing to remember is that uh
systems can can generate information but
it takes people to turn that information
into knowledge and insights and that's
that's really the key about what we're
talking about
um the career paths available
um
be a data analyst data analyst being the
general term for people who extract
information insights from data in
arbitrary areas then you can
kind of specialize into business analyst
which is what we're talking about today
and then project manager or other roles
that take that that set of skills and
build upon it so
if you're looking to enter into the
career as a business analyst that's one
path if you're already in a career and
you want to leverage that career with
business analytics skills
you have the ability to to move up your
salary scale where you are so
um
this is a all to say that this is a key
to a well-paying
career whether it's in business
analytics particularly or using business
Analytics
to empower yourself as a manager or
executive
but is that a fair statement
yeah but I tend to believe that I tend
to believe that of course these claims
such assumptions are basis I may be
various surveys conducted uh by various
consultancies uh so that seems super
generative belief yes uh so we uh I do
see firsthand essay bases the data that
we have exposure to so this is let's say
this these things these skills are in
demand and people tend to get this
better compared to say some other uh
expertise in other functional areas yeah
by the way the source for these numbers
is Glassdoor India so these are current
in the job market
so you talk about uh
being able to engage in a business
analytics career and the kind of the
graphic at the right hand side talks
about
how this role exists at the intersection
of a number of different skill areas
um so you
talk about
why it's important to build out a broad
range of skills even if you're going to
specialize in just one particular area
talk about business analytics as the
general heading for the skills but that
includes different types of statistical
analysis
for descriptive functions for
prescriptive uh
Direction on what to do and then
predictive to tell you what is likely to
happen
um
data analytics of course is the set of
tools
the data scientists will provide to you
to
uh
analyze and understand the data and then
the those tools include regression
methods
hypothesis testing and so forth but the
the tools of visualization and
storyboarding are very important because
once you create the insights extract the
insights from the data you've got to be
able to communicate those insights
so being able to tell the story being
able to
provide visualizations of the data and
putting that into interactive dashboards
that managers and Executives can
understand that's really also a very
important aspect
of business analysis isn't it
yeah sure and uh
we also the things are listed in the
bullet points are uh sort of uh sort of
the common themes which emerge as you
can actually State uh so say uh business
analysis uh would require an overlap uh
with say uh maybe the technical
knowledge of the particular process but
nonetheless there are some generic uh
say thematic things which emerge uh of
course uh some things are that very
industry specific so some things are
more applicable to say Finance so you
could be doing say portfolio
optimization I think the optimization at
the back end is sort of genetic so
there's applications for instance in our
production planning we wanted to be
scheduling or employee roster making uh
so some of these things are so generic
and then they have specific information
specific application in specific
Industries or functional areas and of
course uh both are required so you need
uh say uh you need to be uh willing to
uh engage with the process just having
say the the competence of the generic
methods uh will get you so far but then
again uh it requires you need to get
your hands dirty uh but nonetheless see
overall these are sort of the theme
which emerge across Associates as you
excluded or already went over the list
so regression yeah another state
multiple regression hypothesis testing
again testing your belief about anything
about the market about a quality control
process control uh with those
subheadings Within These but say a
broadly yeah
these are things tend to reoccur across
processes across Industries across
businesses
um and storyboarding visualization is by
no means a simple task so say uh some
complex analysis can through uh maybe
upwards or what lag data points and then
you need to that's uh it's a task in
itself to find out uh to pinpoint the
thing uh for which you conducted the
analysis to pinpoint that and uh yeah
you have to perform another set of
routines on on top of it and visualizing
that is by no means a trivial a task and
then again then getting the information
in the right format to the right people
to take some maybe actions some
decisions faces that uh see we are still
reporting or building interactive
dashboards so yeah yeah I
I'll share an Insight I got from uh one
of the senior decision analysts at uh
Salesforce
who uh talked about the interaction
between
the analytic and decision support area
and the users and
we always think of
the interaction is being
the user comes to you and says I want to
find out about this particular thing
and you
look into the data find the right
analytic tool and then come back to them
with answers but he pointed out that
very often
you'll go to the users and say we now
know how to find out this kind of
information
would that be useful to you so it's it's
really a place where it's a
collaborative effort between
you
analytics role and the users of the
information whether the management role
operations role executives
type of thing so it's it's a pretty
exciting field because it puts you at
the center of
strategy and planning for your for your
organization I'm going to ask that first
poll question
and
with this poll question goes into is
what has stopped you we're all here to
talk about
learning certification in business
analysis and what has stopped you in the
audience from
taking a course at this type taking that
first step
choose more than one of these reasons
I'll leave this open just for another
five seconds
so please do put in your
answers hit the submit button I will
close the poll
now
so the chief concern of our audience is
getting
practical exposure feeling confident the
program would give you a practical
experience that you you could use to
demonstrate
your new set of skills and that
Harkens back to what Professor Sharma
just said about
getting your hands dirty then finding a
program with a comprehensive curriculum
is very important
and the third is finding a program that
will fit into your schedules working
professional so
we'll talk about those aspects of the
business analytics for strategic
decision making program and
from IIT rookie delivered by smarter I'm
sorry simply learn and in collaboration
with IBM for some of the course content
this is a six-month program fully online
so did you want me to continue with that
description Professor do you want to go
ahead
and talk about the kind of General
points of the program
um there are there's a lot of
pre-recorded content and I think IBM
takes uh some of the online live virtual
classrooms we also have master classes
in uh in between so where we could see
say for instance I'm taking a live class
I think 27 next month so which is an
opportunity to either uh discuss revisit
uh maybe some things which have been
covered in the videos or maybe expand on
it if people have appetite uh the
participants the Learners in the course
of appetite
um and there are of course checks also
where you've gone through some material
then there are some q a that uh need to
um
be able to get through and of course it
gives lots of flexibility with the
pre-recorded content it's a sort of a
the optimal mix between uh the the
pre-recorded and the live ones because
uh again there's this tension between uh
flexibility and uh say live session of
course have by her engagement but then
again
um several people find it difficult to
find that it's sort of a trade-off
between them and sort of trying to find
that sweet spot
um and uh there'll be case studies in
the handsome projects as well yeah
that's correct and it's fully online so
it's all on one platform so you're
taking your live virtual classes on the
same platform that gives you virtual
machines to do your uh integrated case
studies and Hands-On projects
um and as the professor just pointed out
while the live classes are scheduled and
you have to meet at those class times
the rest of the material you can do on
anytime the rest of the week 24x7 the
platform is always available available
their support always available you have
people that you can turn to whether you
want to pose questions to your peers or
instructors or whether you want to turn
to the 24x7 help desk
so you have the ability if you're
working at three o'clock in the morning
um on a particular project and turn to
somebody in case you've reached a doubt
or a blocker so we'll also be talking
about the curriculum in a moment
um so the end of the process you receive
of course the certificate
from IIT rookie that tells the world
that they stand behind your education
your acquisition of these skills because
you completed the program and
successfully demonstrated those skills
you'll get certificates along the way
for the different component courses
within the program including the IBM
courses and you'll also have access to
other content from IBM with hackathons
ask me anything sessions master classes
so that you get some additional exposure
to folks in industry and then one aspect
that we are very proud to provide for
simply learn is job assist
career assistance where we will help
with your job search by providing you
tools through our Partner II
IAM jobs
may ask a mohan to talk about that in a
little while
so Professor can you tell us about the
IIT
murky
background and Advantage why that this
is
a great Institution for this program
yeah sure so you have a nice picture
there so uh yeah that is uh the the main
building Thompson Building uh of IIT to
keep and it's usually the the pictures
according to key uh so rookies are
located in the state of uttarakhand
which some tripod was
um away from Delhi and um yeah that is
uh where the Institute is administered
from the building that you see in the
picture and um yep uh we have um more
than I think close to 550 faculty
members
um more than 8 000 students across say
undergraduate program uh the
postgraduate program and and the PHD
programs uh so upwards of uh I think 23
departments full-time departments and uh
other different centers and uh so my
affiliation is at the department of
management studies and uh so is the
affiliation of other other faculty
members uh so you have Professor Ramesh
Professor Amit
Professor uh tabati and Professor anik
uh
so when the program is launched
everybody of us was based at IIT root
key at the management studies department
but now we have of course Professor
Aditi has moved to
um IIM Kolkata and Professor chapati is
at the IIT Khan proof and our department
ranks first uh in 2020 rankings in the
in the in the research and professional
practices category and ours is uh sort
of we recently celebrated uh our uh as
an Institute a 175 years of its
foundation sort of a set of uh in 1847
and uh it's uh we'll be proud to be the
oldest technical institutions uh
institution in southeast uh South Asia
and our own Department are the
management studies department has
celebrated is celebrating in fact
currently the 25th year of its
establishment and uh
that's uh that's brief about the
institution and I encourage you to visit
the website
um so iatr uh website or the department
websites and even the faculty profiles
are backgrounds uh there's a lot of
details on the websites about whatever
we teach what all we uh research what
projects we are doing
um yeah so there's plenty of information
and I encourage you to engage with the
the websites thank you and that just
emphasizes
the value of uh
education program with IIT rookie we
enhanced that with the partnership with
IBM
because they can provide industry
standard uh
courses in certain technical areas they
can provide you with as I mentioned
exposure to IBM personnel and Industry
Personnel through the the different
sessions you'll have access to and
you'll receive
certificates
from IBM for those specialized courses
so those are in addition to an adding
value to the IIT rookie certificate
so we're very proud of that affiliation
as well
um
so I'd like
Mohan if you could and I don't want to
put you on the spot if you prefer I can
do this for you but I'd like to talk
about I'd like you to talk about the job
assist service and what it provides to
our
learners
yep show us to it uh hi everyone uh so
in terms of job assist uh we would be
providing the job assist would be
provided from the simply Land End and we
have partnered with various mentors like
we mentioned here like IAM jobs and you
would be getting a premium uh service
from their rent along with some of these
sessions for preparing your resume to
ensure that you landed the right job so
this is the support okay yeah we have
the slide here so we have a job portal
where you can get access to the premium
jobs uh with IM I am jobs portal and
then there are some Services where you
can update your resume based on the
courses you will learn and based on the
jobs which are applying for and there
would be some other webinars where it it
will help you to prepare yourself for
the interview so more details we can
share it later yeah
yeah I think it's always important to
point out the resume review and rewrite
service and the interview service
because
um
today your resume when you submit it
will not be seen by a human being until
it is processed by an AI bot which will
extract information from your resume and
pair it to the job description either
filter you in or filter you out of the
job search
um so it's important to have your resume
written in a style the AI bot can easily
recognize your experience and your
skills filter you in
but then it still has to go in front of
a human being when it arrives on their
desk or on their screen they need to to
see that resume and have visual appeal
from it
prompts them to contact you so that's a
real art form that the resume writers
can help you with and similarly with the
res the interview practice you can
so many different kinds of interviews
that you must go through in a new job
search or seeking a promotion where you
have
phone screen you have the skills
interviews for evaluating your technical
capabilities and then you have the
cultural fit
to look at your
ability to be a team player your work
ethic you're fit with the corporation
culture so all of those interview types
have different flavors and require you
to put different sides of you forward
and being able to practice each one of
those is really a great benefit of this
program
uh and as Milan said there's a number of
webinars that we run which give you
access to advice on how to
do your job search advice on how to care
for and feed your career over time
um and then look at prospects within
different technical areas and even take
some
mini lessons for free all of these by
the way are free webinars we run them
definitely they're accessible from
everywhere
and
the other part of this is the fact that
you have industry aligned projects
which give you the ability to
take a challenge from industry
something that's a real life case study
and
apply your skills learn how to solve
that problem
provide the solution so
um Professor how does that process work
in the courses
demonstrate some Hands-On and then um of
course uh conclude uh say with uh with
the case study or uh
clock mode I say about some practical
application and then maybe leave a leave
with an assignment but again the depth
uh uh
if in the loaders experience it will be
easy difficult to moderate depends on
their exposure uh so this is usually a
fair uh there's a proper Continuum uh so
that the content is pitched uh and I'll
say A medium level so not not too too
difficult not too easy and um yeah some
of the problems
um problems which are provided by The
Faculty members and of course some of us
have say large experience for instance
across across the four or five faculty
members that we have they do have a
considerable industry experience as well
uh so uh again uh if the loaders uh how
the loaders registered it just it'll be
Continuum so some things might probably
uh come a little uh lazy some things
might be a little difficult
um but then yeah we do try so especially
say case studies uh say in my content
the content which I have recorded So I
speak more about say some electricity
sector so there is other area I
specialize in
um yeah so
yeah and of course uh yeah that is how
it is structured
right and as you said because people
have different experiences of of how
difficult they find it there's always
support uh where you can turn to uh your
peers your instructors uh even the help
desk from Simply learn
to get assistance to help keep you on
track and keep you up with the materials
so you shouldn't feel like
um you would be out of your depth you'll
always have somebody to to help you make
that
um
transition from one course to the next
successfully
we talk about the eligibility in the
prerequisites so there's a drive to
apply the business analytics Concepts
you have to have that
this is targeted at working
professionals so you do have to have at
least six years of work experience
um but you do not have to come into this
with any prior coding experience or
technology know-how so this is uh the
type of program that will equip you to
apply business analytics skills in your
current career
um or pivot to a business analytics a
role within your organization or in a
new job
so let's ask this question about
how much experience you folks in the
audience do have
I will
write this poll now
pretty straightforward so I'm just going
to leave this open for about 20 seconds
and I'll close the poll in five four
three
two one
say about a quarter of our audience
if I'm reading that right have more than
five years of experience
a lot of you are still studying so
this is something that it will be
appropriate for you down the road but um
we'll keep in touch with you about that
but for the folks of you who have more
years of experience this is an ideal
program for you
foreign
to how this program prepares you this is
what's inside the program and how it
gets your job ready
so I just want to mention the learning
environment
um it's all done
through the learning management system
that allows you to see the components of
your curriculum
take your live classes
through the virtual classroom on your
laptop or desktop
and also to do your labs and tests in
those areas
complete those submit those and have
them assessed all through the same
platform
Capstone project which we'll talk about
in a bit and
and progress tracking which allows you
to see which courses you've completed
how far you are along in each class in
each course
generate a certificate once you complete
a course that lets you unlock the next
course in your series versus I mentioned
several times the support tools which
include a community
um
social media type bulletin board as well
as
the 24x7 help desk and other automated
tools to answer your questions so
this learning environment
available to you 24x7
and
the live classes are scheduled need to
be prepared to attend those but
everything else is available to you on
your schedule
when you feel that you have the time to
do it and much of the material is
Professor Sharma said
pre-recorded videos can be accessed on
your tablet or your smartphone so you
can take this learning with you wherever
you go
so Professor if we go through the
program curriculum and how it builds
people's skills in a stepwise fashion
um yeah I think we progress from bottom
to uh top uh left to right so at the
bottom we have the orientation session
um so um
yeah so maybe some more detail uh the
version that you're doing now
um maybe in some more details so we uh
we prep our Orient or dispose uh the
Learners uh towards uh what's to come
and then uh the foundations the
foundational Concepts uh about uh data
uh analytics that could include uh say a
probability statistics uh some linear
algebra
um yeah some basic calculus so these as
if we basically pull upon some of the
ideas so again they're all
um uh vast areas in themselves but the
but then for business uh and again uh we
don't need to know everything about uh
everything so we pick and choose save
from calculus uh how to optimize a
function how to write set notation and
um uh what means quadratic optimization
or whatnot then from probability uh
Elementary
um
plotting histograms of various
categories of probability distributions
and and so on and then say building one
upon the other uh so individually they
are a simple simple Concepts but then
eventually you can become really really
powerful uh powerful they equip you to
then uh ask uh increasingly interesting
and challenging questions uh about
business business processes uh so take
maybe a quality control uh yeah think a
production planning or there are several
examples those of you who know uh
probably can relate to but I'm referring
to there's a few who don't uh it's okay
you can always um yeah maybe once we get
exposed to these domains you'll find
more
um statistical analysis uh regression
um and uh and and other Advanced
Techniques multiple regression Logistics
exploratory data analyzes and
visualization so R has a set of
libraries which are very very powerful
and of course there are other tools out
there as well a good set of libraries in
in python as well which allows you to
handle same uh multi-dimensional data
sets and perform really powerful visuals
uh trying to explore maybe uh
correlations or heat maps and render the
detail in a manner which is very easy to
interpret and then Predictive Analytics
and then once you have uh sort of
understood or established some
relationships then over due to about it
so one thing is it helps you summarize
uh the load of information that is there
and understand key patterns and then of
course the next thing is then you want
to anticipate what's going to happen
next and then position yourself
accordingly uh take your actions or
strategies make strategies accordingly
and uh prediction then prescription is a
sort of the two different things so
prescriptive usually we do optimization
and things like that so we call them
prescription so having maybe made a
forecast for the next uh next quarter
then how do you maybe plan your
production how do you do your master
production schedule and those kind of
things that's prescriptive
and uh machine learning of these are
several paradigms so machine learning
again is AI is a big thing to think
maybe you're thinking of uh uh uh so
maybe this uh text uh text generation uh
so chats GPT is there or Picasso is
there so of course uh we don't go there
so we don't want to learn maybe a
natural language processing or um um or
say those Concepts which are very very
core AI but then again there are other
paradigms uh say
um reinforcement learning is there uh
there is principle component say
unsupervised learning
um say we do clustering K means
clustering principle componential
answers and uh of course supervised
learning so little regression some
things which historically or uh hitherto
would refer to under the category of uh
say statistical analysis also qualifies
in some sense as some paradigms of uh
say machine learning so to reason about
what constitutes learning
um and then all of them coming together
in Capstone project which are where it's
uh so again uh each of these uh concepts
are individually
um can be simple can be complex in their
own right uh say I'm thinking maybe a
singular value decomposition from from
linear algebra so you need quite an
advanced knowledge of literature algebra
to be able to grasp that but then again
we don't necessarily maybe as a business
analyst need to know uh the too much
underlying details so the two the
concepts are Advanced enough that we
have their implementations in some
programming languages as packages and we
just need to run with that then and then
uh pull all these things together and
then see uh what what works what is able
to uh sort of deliver some actionable
insight and Capstone is essentially
where we have a real world problem maybe
something open-ended we need to apply it
yourself because uh I think that's a
that's a scheme itself to be able to
find out what sort of if somebody is
there to tell you uh what to apply and
what kind of insights to to to to
generate then I think that's uh that's
one set of things through this one
competence then to be able to find or to
be able to determine uh how where to
begin uh that's uh that's something
that's another category of competence
and then I think uh in the Capstone
that's the idea there's a much more
open-ended problem
um yeah and uh on the writing sites we
have a bunch of electives so uh master
classes industrial master classes uh
mathematical optimization visualization
and so all those would be available as
electives
yeah and the electives are available at
no extra charge so that you can take as
many or a few of them as you wish we
always recommend that you take as many
as you have the interest in and the time
for because they enrich your your
understanding especially the master
classes because they what you hear live
from
folks like Professor Sharma along the
way as you do the projects the case
studies you will be using these various
tools and
you
don't just learn about them you have to
apply them
so
in each course there's a
case study or course end project that
correct
put you on the spot doctor yeah yes
there are course in projects after each
module yeah and so in each of those
projects you'll be using the tools that
are appropriate to each
uh of the the courses you're studying
and you'll need to learn how to use the
tool and then actually use it apply it
in the project as the professor said
when you get to the Capstone where
you're going to tie together all the
skills you've learned
you'll then have a toolkit pull from to
create that integrated project for that
larger
Challenge
and that leads into this slide which
Professor described the Capstone is
pulling together they're all over the
uh different skills that you learn along
the way
um
so you get to choose a project from
several different industry domains
choose from from those the ones that
interests you the most
and you'll work with a faculty advisor
for several weeks checking in with them
weekly on
your progress and make sure that you're
staying on track not getting stuck on
any doubts or blockers and
um so at the end of this process you'll
have created Your solution
to the challenge
so
have you been involved in doing the
Capstone projects with the students or
uh
have direct experience with that
professor
um
no not not not so far not for this
program no okay so you'd be working with
one of the other faculty members um
checking in with them and that allows
you to kind of stay on track so that
even as you're required to do the work
yourself and build your own personal
project uh you can make sure that you're
not instead getting stuck anywhere
the
wonderful thing about the Capstone
project is like all the other projects
you do in the program goes into your
portfolio
so you build up this
portfolio of actual experience that you
have in solving challenges in business
Analytics
that way you can
provide evidence
proves that you have the skills that
you've learned
you can back up your claims to any
prospective employer or to your current
employer if you're looking for more
responsibility or promotion
salary hike that type of
the
here are the program advisors from IIT
rookie Professor you're one of them and
you work with the others so you can
tell us a little about it about
in total there are five faculty members
and uh as I mentioned earlier so a
couple of them have changed institutions
uh since we launched the program So
currently uh you see three of us on the
screen
um so Professor Ramesh he's again all
three of us are in the operations area
um and uh we teach different courses and
uh there's some detail is uh the
associate professor and the two of us
are assistant professors and um yeah
Amit earlier was at uh I think for three
four years he was a faculty member there
um and um
yum and you see some other credentials
there and more details uh as I said
earlier I encourage you to visit the
on the website for the department so
there that lists all the uh the
Publications the projects the introdust
the teaching into tasks alongside with
the information that you see on the on
the screen now
um yeah so that uh probably is helpful
for some Learners to sort of
yeah and
as your other two colleagues who are now
at other institutions but are still
within the the program so
um Professor Mukherjee and Professor
chapati we have uh there's a slight typo
there so it's anik Mukherjee uh so yeah
yeah
and uh Professor tripathi also you know
he's now based at uh
um is a professor in finance and
Professor Ahmed is in the area of
Information Systems so yeah
thank you um not correct that for future
editions so what I wanted to do is to
share with our audience
this uh
short video from one of our Learners who
went through the program and he'll talk
about his experience
yeah
my ticket long experience in the
business development sector has made me
realize you must know how to analyze
data and statistics sorry
it's to grow in your career I plan to
use the business analytics strategic
decision making course which I did from
IIT roorkee and simple learn to pursue
the Senior Management roles
I have 12 years plus of experience in
business development currently I am
planning to launch my own startup with
my friends recently I realized the
importance of data analytics for making
business decisions when I started my
career that technology was not Advanced
and data is not readily available but
now it is I have also realized that
companies are looking for people with
the knowledge of machine learning so I
decided to choose a professional
certificate before children simply learn
I look for other platform too but the
course simple line provides covers
everything the association with IIT
rookie makes the certification
internationally recognized in fact my
journey will simply learned begin when I
took a course from skill up and I was
really impressed it made me confident
about choosing this course my experience
with simply learn has been amazing the
course is comprehensive and covers
subject of my interest it has R it has
python it has SQL but also something I
have always wanted to learn now I think
I'm ready to make a new beginning
I am going to change my domain from
Business Development to Big Data
learning and Analysis I am looking
forward handling project and handling
the profit and loss of my organization I
believe the learning from the course
will be very beneficial there I wanted
to be in a Senior Management Group and I
believe this course will help me to get
there I want to thank my wife who has
been very supportive throughout my
journey I am happy that we have such an
amazing platform which actually quench
my thirst of learning you should never
stop learning
uh
I actually agree with him you should
never stop learning
uh so let's ask this question based on
what um
Professor Sharma Mohan and I have shared
with you are you
interested in enrolling in the program
full question open just for about
another
10 seconds because it's yes or no
close it in five four three
two one
share the results
so more than 80 percent of the folks in
our audience said that they are
interested
I will share with you now
how to make that happen so the
enrollment steps are very
straightforward
I'm going to put into the chat bear with
me and do this
be
uh
uh how you get started with the program
email us at ask us simplylearn.net
just put that into the chat now and
we'll verify your work history which is
the main
um
requisite prerequisite for the program
we'll also uh
verify your
aptitude and your desire to study
analytics Zoom is going to kick me off
for a second I'll be right back so
pardon the interruption
we'll take a moment
apologies for that
um
so returning back to our slide
so the next cohort starts 11 May so
you're coming up fairly quickly
um the price of the program is one lock
forty nine thousand
uh you can do Emi financing at 5071 a
month
and
we say act now for two reasons one if
you act now and enroll in this cohort
you will receive a 20 discount from
those fees
just for being here at this webinar so
that will be part of the follow-up email
to you but you can also mention that
when you email us at ask us at
simplylearn.net
um the other reason we say act now is
because the cohort sizes uh do have
certain limitations because of the need
for the live sessions to to be limited
so the instructors have the ability to
pay attention and devote time to each
member so we can't take on an unlimited
number of people in each cohort and
therefore it's important that you get
started right away and claim your place
in cohort so we encourage you to email
us right away and we also remind you
that if you have an employer who offers
tuition reimbursement some employers do
you can ask them about assistance with
these fees so
for those of you who said you were
interested
how soon
you plan to get started is it something
you start in the May cohort
or are you looking a little further down
the road
[Music]
I'll leave this open for another
five seconds
get your answers in please hit that
submit button
I will end the poll
now
sharing the result
if I look at the total
more than 50 percent of our audience
pardon my weak eyes lean to the screen
uh more than fifty percent of our
audience wants to get started either in
May or in June July
um great you would want to contact uh
ask us at simplylearn.net
for those of you looking further down
the road please do also contact us at
ask us at simplylearn.net and we will
keep in touch with you keep you advised
on future cohorts and answering the
other questions for you so
at this point we can go into questions
and answers so I will stop sharing my
screen
we can go right ahead and take a look at
questions that have come in
through the Q a and chat
so
uh first question of course is will we
get a certificate at the end of this
webinar
uh you'll get you can request in the
next question after the Q a you'll be
able to request a proof of attendance
for this webinar it doesn't certify that
you have any new skills but it does
certify that you are here
um
and you list out companies you're tied
up with
so
Professor what are some of the the
companies that you've noticed people
coming in from different employees not
that you necessarily have a formal
relationship with them but what are some
of the companies who send folks to learn
with IIT so I think probably uh I think
I'm not sure if it's uh if it's
separating to the the bats coming in or
is it about uh the placement services so
if it's the former so we do have say
again a range of people so we've had
people who have had to say more than a
decade of experience and say if we
Supply to working as consultants in in
Erp or those areas
um yeah
um sap
um yeah and um
about the placements I think Mohan
probably will have a better visibility
of that okay
I think I'll speak a word in the
presentation we will have the premium
membership from IAM jobs and through
that you will be able to apply for the
premium jobs listed on that portal so
more details we can share it with you
when you can connect with our
Consultants
somebody asked about
getting to our course page in the
brochure and we'll share that link after
the Q a
um
so you'll see some of that information
also there
um
so
the lender asks why six years of
experience why have you established that
as a prerequisite professor
I think um the thinking was that uh uh
otherwise it's uh we have to keep that
to get the bright segment of people in
other ways it so happens that the the
content becomes it becomes very hard to
design the content so if it's a very
broad spectrum then um uh then it
becomes difficult to get the engagement
if if it allows Refreshers as well then
uh the either the content looks too slow
or to the people who are already
experienced uh and we believe see the
programming again I think is not a
practice is not a prereq because that
thing I can I think people can learn is
if they have exposure to the processes
in fact then they have the new what are
the unknowns uh and what can now be
known about the process which then could
be it could be useful so there is a
thinking segmentation is important
otherwise uh it becomes it goes all over
the place then it's very difficult to
cater to the wide spectrum of uh
expectations and uh the requirements of
the Learners so yeah so that's that's
allows us to uh then yeah design it's
from the design
we have a comment from Peter who points
out that he has more than five years of
experience but he's still studying so uh
given that the uh that there's no degree
requirement for this program your
experience Peter should qualify you for
this so that's that's the thing
um
a question from a student right now what
course would be helpful and you can
actually contact uh ask us at
simplylearn.net or go to our website to
look at some of the other
options that you might have
um
so people asked this question does the
program help Personnel who have been
in analytical decision support to their
line managers
um but with less knowledge of the
processes that are executed at work so
will this help people to
um provide better analytical support to
their managers and
executives
um yeah again uh we encourage you to uh
say look closely at the course contents
and then make the decision for yourself
uh so of course uh that is what you try
to uh to to marry uh through the real
problem and and the skills that are out
there and uh we bring both to the table
and then uh sort of try to establish an
interface between them
um yeah uh I think it should be helpful
then again uh make a make a conscious uh
decision and uh do do your due diligence
so of course uh you can write an email
as well to get some more details if you
have some specific queries
um broadly sort of you have listed The
Core theme that I've alluded to some of
the some of the some of the underlying
topics uh as well uh so we hope it's
useful but then again uh uh it's best
other to take the decision uh for
yourself
with respect to the the knowledge of
your the processes being executed at
work uh the the physical process uh if I
understand that question
the more you understand about it what
work your organization does and how for
example uh your product is produced uh
the better you can understand what the
data about those processes means better
uh decision support you can provide so
it's always uh helpful to gain that
knowledge as well we have a question uh
having a math stream compulsory
so uh things uh so yeah I'd say
analytics are low letting um uh it helps
if you've had some maths maybe at 12
standard or maybe if you have studied
engineering uh but uh again in
analytical aptitude for sure I think is
needed uh match compulsory again uh go
through
um the contents if you think you can
cope up I do I wouldn't say it's
necessary but in a quantitative aptitude
an analytical aptitude I think is
certainly required because
um I mean it's a primarily analytics we
work with a lot of numbers
um we have do a bunch of things on it so
I wouldn't say math is a compulsory uh
an aptitude is definitely a yes needed a
quantitative aptitude
um it's not required to come in with the
math background but it is required to
learn about the the principles within
the program that draw on mathematics
um
is it an online course yes this is
delivered fully online through our uh
platform
and
uh
Federica asks
tell us about placement offers after
completing this course so Mohan you
might want to comment but um the job
assist program is to help you with
your job search
it's not a job guarantee program per se
so you could tell people about how that
process works a little bit
sure so as we mentioned during this
slide it's not a job guarantee program
uh so we'll assist you to find uh jobs
through I am jobs premium membership
okay
um so you you can actually consider this
asset assistance not as a guaranteed one
from our end
and more details you can see on the
website where we can actually see what
are the uh average placement for
simulator and Learners and which
background they are coming from so it
depends on a lot of things right it
depends on your background what's your
experience
like that
um Ibrahim says I have no I.T experience
can I still do this course
uh yes uh so it is uh for sure uh uh
yeah not not a pre-rank and again
um so uh in how these things get
actually deployed so a team you
typically would require ID getting the
right set of information to the right
sets of people uh so there's a lot of
that going on but for this course per se
uh again I think it's uh not a lot of
mandatory requirement and then I can
take the final question I think do we
get an ITR alumni status
um no not with this certificate program
um I am there are some other uh
offerings I think there's an emba or uh
the department runs that program that
that gives you that but that's a longer
engagement that's a full full-fledged
MBA program
um but the uh not this the certification
so this certification is run through uh
the center for continuing education and
uh so you get a uh yeah a verifiable
certificate is issued uh through uh the
center for continuing education
okay
all right thank you very much and
uh
uh that covers our questions if we
haven't gotten to your question if we
didn't see it please accept my apology
um but again you can contact us through
the ask us at simplylearn.net email
address and
follow up we will also be sending you a
follow-up email after this program
with links to the recording of the
session and with also links to
um
the discount code or the offer that we
mentioned and I'm going to put into
the chat right now
how to contact us
both through the email address and
through our web page so
pull that up
all right and now you have the link to
the web page in that
I will ask one last question provided
Zoom does not
interfere with me again
and with this question this allows you
to request that
certificate for being here this evening
but also it will let us know that you
need us to reach out to you
Zoom is going to interfere with me so
hold on for just
let me launch this last poll
again answer yes if you are
interested in getting that certificate
for tonight's session
or want us to reach out to you with more
information on enrollment
and I'll close the poll in five four
three
two one
and about 60 percent of you said yes so
these expect to hear from us
all of you of course will be receiving
the link to the recording of the session
and
at this point I'd like to thank
Professor Sharma
well I'm George for being here
and being so generous with the time and
knowledge
thank you professor
um thank you uh Stuart I think you have
a little bit uh very well so thank you
appreciate it and thank you Mohan
thank you sir thank you professor
and I want to thank everybody who uh
made it here this evening attended the
session
we want to
welcome you into the Learning Community
with IIT rookie and simply learn so we
hope that we will see you in future the
QR code can take you to our
program webpage and you also have the
link in your chat so at this point we're
going to conclude the webinar
and
as you jump into the chat grab those
links and we will see you
again soon we hope thank you again for
being here